esto que tenemos aquí es la imagen de
fibonacci fibonacci uno de los
matemáticos más famosos de todos los
tiempos él fue matemático en la italia
medieval y fue famoso por sus números
números de fibonacci bueno él no los
descubrió fueron descubiertos muchos
siglos antes en la india pero él los
popularizó especialmente en el occidente
y los números de fibonacci son super
simples los primeros dos son definidos
como 0 y 1 y todos los números que
siguen después de estos son la suma de
los dos anteriores entonces lo que voy a
construir aquí es una secuencia de
números de fibonacci la sucesión de
fibonacci y el que sigue es 0 + 11 el
que sigue 1 + 12 el número que sigue
después de este es uno más 2 igual a 3 2
+ 3 igual a 5 35 es 8
58 es 13 8 13 es 21 13 21 es igual a 34
y con la sucesión de fibonacci podemos
hacer muchísimas cosas padres pero
probablemente la cosa más padre de estos
números es que podemos poner y poner más
números a la sucesión y tomar los
últimos dos términos y no terminar allí
sino que se pueden sumar y agregar otro
a la serie en realidad no encontramos
los últimos podríamos estar haciendo
esto para siempre y obtener una
secuencia de longitud de arbitraria pero
digamos que tomamos estos dos últimos
que tenemos aquí 21 y 34 y tenemos que
la razón de 21 entre 34 es un número muy
cercano a la razón dorada un número
cercano a la razón dorada y los animo a
que busquen sobre la razón dorada en
wikipedia y en internet y encontrarán
una fuente de cosas fascinantes y
místicas sobre este número y lo que es
padre de esta sucesión de fibonacci
que dan una mayor aproximación a la
razón dorada se agregan otro término a
la secuencia el siguiente término aquí
es 21 34 que es igual a 55 así que la
razón de 34 entre 55 es más cercana más
cercana
a la razón dorada
así que si realmente quieren una mejor
aproximación a la razón dorada pueden
tomar unos términos altísimos de esta
sucesión de fibonacci ya saben sólo
sumando dos términos previos y
obteniendo el siguiente y podrían
obtener una buena aproximación de la
razón dorada con los últimos dos
términos que obtengan bueno estos son
los números de fibonacci de eso se trata
la sucesión de fibonacci y quiero lanzar
les un reto
quiero que escriban ya hemos hecho
algunos ejemplos usando el factorial y
ahora quiero que escriban una
implementación de una función que genere
el último término en la sucesión de
fibonacci entonces la función sería algo
así esto sería en la sucesión de
fibonacci si llamamos una función
fibonacci déjenme darles un ejemplo
bueno voy a escribirlo de este lado en
minúsculas tengo una función y le llamo
fibonacci
y no importa en qué lenguaje lo hagan
hemos estado programando en python y
creo que sería más fácil trabajar en
python si llamo a una función digamos
fibonacci de uno lo que quiero que esto
haga es el primer término lo voy a
aclarar muy bien y deberíamos siempre
aclarar esto especialmente en
computación porque no siempre tenemos
claro cuál es el primer término y ahora
lo voy a hacer el primer término no va a
ser este de aquí este es el término cero
y este es el primer término este es el
segundo este es el tercero este es el
cuarto y así sucesivamente
entonces si bonacci de uno el primer
término de la sucesión será este uno de
aquí nos debería regresar 1 fibonacci de
0 nos debería regresar 0 fibonacci de 3
nos debería regresar
1 2 3 nos debería regresar 2 fibonacci
fibonacci de 5 nos debería regresar
0 1 2 3 4 5 nos debería regresar 5 y lo
que quiero que hagan es que escriban una
función en la que puedan poner cualquier
argumento aquí y que nos regrese ese
término de la sucesión de fibonacci